I am valaria Peter you know I work at
Cosmo starter laboratory in cell
pericyclic since two years and in
particular I work on cosmology which is
the study of the universe its evolution
and its content and I do this research
at the Department of astrophysics I am a
theorist but I work on comparing data
from different observations with the
predictions from different theories in
particular to explain what dark energy
is and so what is the source of energy
that causes the acceleration of the
universe and so the expansion of the
universe to accelerate
we don't know exactly what I can achieve
it could be fluid that tends to
effectively contrast the gravitational
attraction or it could be a sign that
the laws of gravity themselves have to
be changed with respect to the theory of
general relativity of Einstein
so with the Euclid space satellites that
would be launched in 2022 and which is
again a very large collaboration in
which I'm involved we will observe
several galaxies in particular billions
of images of galaxies and millions of
distances of galaxies and this will
allow us to understand the evolution of
the universe and also the growth of
structures so how all the galaxies and
clusters of galaxies manage to form and
evolve in time and this is a powerful
probe to understand what dark matter is
and what a Kennedy is so this can lead
to understand more about the theory that
describe the nature of dark energy and
what actually causes this cosmic
acceleration